là je pense il y a des sénateurs ici qui
avaient demandé un débat avec vote oui
mais le gouvernement refusé non mais
pourquoi pas mais si vous voulez moi je
pense que c'est pas le moment de
polémiquer on sait malheureusement à
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez l'anupes
qui est dévorée par l'antisionisme qui
flirte malheureusement parfois avec des
sentiments toute la nuupè plus négatif
non là une partie de laanupes mais pas
seulement votre question est
intéressante parce que le gouvernement
veut réduire le problème de l'anupes
avec Israël à seulement les insoumis or
vous le savez ceux qui ont déposé depuis
de mandats une résolution parlementaire
pour insulter Israël en considérant que
c'est un régime d'apartaï et pas une
démocratie ce sont les communistes ceux
qui accueille le mouvement BDS le
mouvement de boycotte Israël qui est le
faonet des antisémites contemporains
c'est la fête de l'Humanité c'est le PCF
voilà il est les vers aussi
malheureusement ont beaucoup flirter
avec ce genre de mouvement donc ce n'est
pas avec notamment le rappeur Médine je
rappelle qu' a fait un tweet antisémite
contre Rachel can il y a seulement 2
mois donc ce sont malheureusement des
mouvements politiques qui sont traversés
par l'antisioniste qui est le nouveau né
de l'antisémitisme mais vous les accusez
d'antisémitisme à l'anupess ah oui à
l'anupess il y a aujourd'hui des figures
qui sont à mon avis
antisémite personnes comme Madame auonau
comme d'autres qui fleurent madame sourd
par exemple qui malheureusement est
vice-président du groupe d'études contre
l'antismit des insoumis euh oui mais les
autres flirtent dans les autres le PCF
et les vers il est vrai utilise
l'antisciionisme mais je pense
malheureusement soit ils sont naïfs soit
c'est un faunet mais vous savez que vous
ayez déjà les deux noms que je vous ai
cité dans les insoumis qui sont pas des
figures anecdotiques hein les insoumis
ont choisi madame sourd pour être
vice-président du groupe d'étude contre
l'antisémitisme sachant que dès qu'elle
peut elle fait des selfies avec les gens
du mouvement boycotte Israël donc ce
sont des mouvements dramatiques donc
voilà le fait qu'il y aurait un vote un
vote en tout cas aujourd'hui dans les
circonstances actuelles avec le niveau
de tension et de provocation des
insoumis me semble un débat tendu il y
aura un débat tendu il y a déjà eu un
débat très tendu vous savez avant les
attaques qui a connu qu'a connu Israël
sur la fameuse résolution des
communistes sur le fait qu'Israël serait
un état d'apparex qui une insulte à la
République
israélienne